تتواصل الاحتجاجات هنا وسط تلابيب المندده
بسياسات رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
والمطالبه بالافراج عن الاسرى والمحتجزين
الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه وكانت هناك
مظاهره اولى شهدت مشاركه نحو
4000 متظاهر رفعوا شعارات تطالب باقاله
حكومه نتنياهو فورا وايضا تطالب باجراء
انتخابات مبكره وهذه التظاهر انتقلت الى
هذا الميدان
وتطالب الاسراع بعقد صفقه تبادل الاسرى
وتتهم نتنياهو على انه حاول او
يحاول تاجيل واعاقه تنفيذ هذه الصفقه
الشعارات
ايضا ومع دخول الحرب
يومها تقول بان نتنياهو عليه فورا ان
يستقيل تتهم بالفساد والكذب اضافه الى هذه
المظاهرات لم تخرج فقط هنا في التلبيب بل
امتدت لمدن اخرى ك حيفا و قيساريا وايضا
بئر السبع
وهذه الاحتجاجات هنا باتت اسبوعيه ورقع
تها تتسع يوما بعد
اخر درغامي الجزيره تلا
ابيب